Where do Jeff Bezos and Richard Branson
get off spending their
own money to go into space
when we already have a scandal-ridden,
and incompetent public
agency for that very purpose?
All Richard Branson ever did
was give away half his fortune
after foisting Tubular Bells
and the Sex Pistols on the world.
All Jeff Bezos ever did was make
a year-long pandemic bearable
by creating the company
that delivered everything
we wanted to our doors within hours.
Maybe Elon Musk is a welfare queen,
but as long as he's
spending his own Doge Coin
and living in a $50,000 prefab
house, who are we to judge?
If AOC's former policy guy is right
that every billionaire
is a policy failure,
then the remedy is taking
the wealth they accumulated
and appropriating it for the government,
which is really just another
name for the things we do
together like manning 800 military bases
in over 70 countries and
spending more on defense
than the next 11 nations combined.
Or wasting half a century punishing people
for recreational drug use
and putting more Americans
per capita in prison than
Cuba, Russia, and China.
Or passing massive COVID relief bills
that only spent 5% of their
totals on actual COVID relief.
There are 724 American billionaires,
worth a total of $4.4
trillion, according to Forbes.
It's a list that includes
entertainment moguls
like Steven Spielberg and Tyler Perry,
and lawyer in training Kim Kardashian.
If it were somehow possible to
liquidate all of that wealth
without causing a market
crash that would obliterate
most of it in the process,
we could cover roughly half
a year of combined local,
state and federal spending.
I'm going to ride a rocket into space,
and it's going to look just like my dick.
Instead of mocking billionaires,
and their penis shaped
rockets millionaires,
like Jon Stewart and Jason Alexander,
should take aim at the federal government,
which is the biggest dick in the room
by a few orders of magnitude.
Our national debt is around $22 trillion
and will continue to climb
in the years to come,
so that by 2050, just
paying interest on the debt,
will account for about a quarter
of every dollar the
federal government spends.
That kind of debt correlates strongly
with sharply reduced economic growth,
which is the only proven way
of improving living standards over time.
In the years to come, the
US will have no choice,
but to raise taxes on
everyone, and slash Medicare
and Social Security, which are
the biggest budget busters.
But, by then, it'll be
too late for a generation
of elderly people to plan accordingly.
And a US debt crisis
could destroy the dollar,
and undermine our entire economy.
There is no way to
confiscate enough wealth
to stave off our looming
fiscal catastrophe.
So instead of harping on rich
people and their rockets,
let's start talking about
the looming debt crisis,
fueled by insane government spending,
and come up with an actual
way to avert catastrophe.